so I live in Groningen and one-way ticket to Groningen
The Hague is more than 29 euros
this is the voicemail of young political The Hague
leave 1 message after the tone
I get something like this on Saturday or don't know for free
train travel in the Netherlands is so expensive
that it is sometimes even cheaper to get 1 plane ticket
can be booked to 1 other city in Europe
and that is of course ridiculous
make it completely free
that will be very difficult
but i think so
that we should all bet
on 1 good accessibility
the costs must certainly go down
and things like the rush-hour levy
we should never want that
VAT on tickets should be abolished
and tickets just have to be much cheaper
I think it is time for the nuclear power plants to come
without energy mix
you work against it
nuclear power plants are often mentioned as the solution
by right-wing political parties
but that is not a solution at all
if you now build 1 nuclear power plant
it takes far too long for it to stand
before it is profitable
i think nuclear energy
1 important part of 1 balanced
energy mix is
are during the days when it rains and the wind is not blowing
then you still need nuclear power plants
to keep your energy up to date
what we find the solution is investing
in green hydrogen
in solar and wind energy
but also save energy